[Musica]
un bellissimo proverbio giapponese dice
che la vita si può cadere sette volte ma
bisogna rialzarsi 8
non importa quante difficoltà
incontriamo quanti fallimenti subiamo la
vita è piena di difficoltà di fallimenti
l'importante è come reagire come faccio
a tirarmi fuori da quelle situazioni
come faccia ritrovare la motivazione per
andare avanti
se c'è una cosa che lo sport della vela
mi ha insegnato lo sport in generale la
vela in particolare è come reagire ai
momenti di difficoltà
la vela è piena di questi episodi è la
mia vita lo è stata ancora di più
la vela ci insegna che anche in mezzo a
una tempesta
possiamo utilizzare il vento a nostro
beneficio e andare più veloce degli
altri più forte degli altri verso la
meta
ma come si fa a uscire concretamente da
queste situazioni di difficoltà
io faccio spesso riferimento al mio al
mio sogno è un sogno che mi è venuto da
bambino quando in televisione
guardavo le regate di coppa america di
allora il moro di venezia ancor prima
azzurra ero con papà guardavo la
televisione e vedevo questi personaggi
come mauro pellaschier barbuto vero
marinaio e anche paul cayard col suo
sguardo aggressivo
con la voglia di vincere e io bambino di
10 anni sognavo segnalo di diventare
come loro
l'ora nei miei eroi
volevo a tutti i costi diventare un
timoniere di coppa america
[Musica]
da bambini è facile puntare in alto
non ci creiamo limiti
pensiamo sia possibile l'impossibile
io ho fatto di tutto per cercare di
realizzare il mio sogno per raggiungere
il mio obiettivo non ho avuto poche
insidie poche difficoltà ma quelle
insidie quelle difficoltà mi hanno
aiutato a diventare quello che sono oggi
durante queste fasi critiche queste
difficoltà è facile avere l'impressione
di essere travolti dalla dalla corrente
bisogna saper reagire ma in tanti ci
parlano di mindset tenacia resilienza
sono però ogni tanto parole che ci
passano attraverso e non le facciamo
nostre cos'è che in realtà ci aiuta a
essere resilienti ci fa diventare
resilienti è questo il punto cruciale
bisogna riaccendere la motivazione
bisogna trovare uno stimolo e questo
stimolo io l'ho trovato nel mio sogno
nel mio sogno iniziale il mio sogno da
bambino
io penso che per raggiungere la propria
meta per raggiungere i propri obiettivi
bisogna ritornare al proprio perché al
proprio sogno
per me è stato così quando ero in
difficoltà
pensavo ma io perché voglio raggiungere
quell'obiettivo quel sogno
a 24 anni ho iniziato una nuova classe
una nuova tipologia di barca si chiama
fortin heiner è una barca nuova per
tutti era una barca molto acrobatica e
mi trovo a mondello il primo anno le
prime uscite di questa barca è veramente
non sapevamo come domarla era un cavallo
imbizzarrito
la giornata era una giornata tranquilla
da un certo punto
entro lo scirocco lo scirocco fa sempre
paura in sicilia arriva forte arriva
cattivo
in quel periodo le previsioni del tempo
non erano molto affidabili ed era nella
novembre le giornate erano corte erano
le quattro del pomeriggio e cominciamo a
rotolare per il mare ci allontana sempre
più da costa
contiamo a scuffiare raddrizzare la
barca eravamo veramente in difficoltà
ancor più in difficoltà quando a un
certo momento andavamo quasi a 15.000 la
cosa si ruppe l'albero non sapevamo
veramente cosa fare
eravamo naufraghi una fra gli in mezzo
al mediterraneo a 15 miglia la costa era
una situazione veramente imbarazzante
quasi buio a un certo momento vediamo un
traghetto un traghetto che veniva da
ustica verso palermo il traghetto ci
vede e lancia l'allarme a terra fa un
giro su se stesso intorno a noi e va via
avevamo la speranza di essere salvati e
il traghetto è andato via è stato un
momento bruttissimo
fortuna vuole che dopo qualche ora un
peschereccio
allarmato dal traghetto che faceva un
giro su se stesso si è avvicinato e ci
ha portato a terra ci ha trainato a
terra quando si arrivate a terra in
piena notte del fortin e non rimaneva
molto lo scafo era danneggiato
l'albero si era spezzato le vele
trainate a strascico dietro
l'imbarcazione erano veramente distrutte
ed era distrutto il nostro morale
avevamo i genitori a terra che ci
aspettavano
ed è stato un momento veramente tragico
tutto quel materiale distrutto che
avevamo con tanto sacrificio comprato e
non a poco è stato un momento veramente
di difficoltà ho messo in discussione
tutto forse dovevo tornare
alla prima barca con cui avevo fatto le
olimpiadi nel 96 il singolo il
semplicissimo laser
in molti mi consigliavano di tornare sul
laser era la strada più facile lastra
più semplice a quel punto mi sono fatto
tante domande
forse era più giusto tornare sull'acer
sul singolo la barca con cui avevo fatto
le olimpiadi l'anno prima che conoscevo
benissimo
avevo già esperienza su quella barca
quindi forse fare un altro olimpiade sul
laser era più giusto e mollare questa
follia della barca acrobatica
tanti mi dicevano di prendere quella
decisione
ma a quel punto davanti a quel video io
tornai al mio sogno cos'era che mi
portava a raggiungere l'obiettivo
forse era a confrontarmi con una barca
così difficile
cambiare una un'altra disciplina
provare a sfidare me stesso e domare
quell'imbarcazione e così feci e
raggiungi tantissimi tantissimi
risultati con con il fortin heiner
vincemmo tantissimo
ed ero contentissimo della scelta che
avevo fatto però anche in momenti in cui
sembra tutto in discesa sembra andare
tutto bene
bisogna stare sempre all'erta
sempre attenti perché la tempesta è
dietro l'angolo si può si può facilmente
tornare in un momento di difficoltà e
così fu per me
alla fine della campagna confortin
heiner dove era andato tutto benissimo
facevo la mia seconda esperienza di
coppa america
nel 2007 eravamo a valentia per quella
che era la terza campagna di coppa
america di luna rossa per me la seconda
la prima campagna coppa america avevo
passata in panchina a auckland nel 2003
era giusto così era era la mia prima
campagna
non avevo l'esperienza forse per per
essere in barca ma nella seconda ci
credevo tanto ricoprivo il ruolo di
stratega quello che si arrampica su
sull'albero e il consigliere del tattico
era una
un periodo bellissimo per me avevo fatto
tutte le regate di preparazione a quella
coppa america da titolare in barca
finalmente gareggiavo su un coppa
america in parte un avvicinamento a quel
sogno iniziale di timonare 1 quando
sarei stato più grande
purtroppo le cose non andarono benissimo
dopo un paio d'anni di preparazione di
regate fatte in barca
due giorni prima
dell'evento ufficiali di coppa america
valentia
mi venne comunicato che non fa non avrei
fatto parte dell'equipaggio titolare
sarei tornato in panchina o in gommone
per meglio dire a guardare le regate non
a viverle da protagonista
è stato un momento terribile
mi sono venuti i mille dubbi ero di
nuovo davanti a un bivio questa volta
ancora più importante
forse era giusto mollare tutto il sogno
non l'avrei forse raggiunto mai
non ci credevo quasi più
ero era un passo da un altro momento
fantastico quello di fare le regate da
titolare come stratega sulla barca e mi
veniva comunicato che al mio posto ci
sarebbe stato un americano che in quel
momento
meritava più di me io non ci credevo non
potevo credere a quelle parole è stato
terribile momento terribile
volevo veramente mollare tutto
poi per fortuna
ho ripensato al mio sogno cos'era lastra
più giusta qual è la strada più giusta
da prendere per alla fine
riuscire a stare al timone di un coppa
america
forse era rimanere lì a imparare e
prendere
assorbire come una spugna tutto quello
che potevo imparare in quei tre mesi che
sarebbero stati difficilissimi seduti su
un gommone e così è stato sono rimasto
lì ad imparare andare avanti a tutti i
costi è stato il mio motto è oggi ne
sono felice è stata la decisione giusta
ho imparato tanto in quei tre mesi tante
cose che mi sono servite poi adesso di
recente quando il timone di copa america
lo finalmente preso
[Musica]
avevo fatto delle scelte importanti fin
da quando ero giovane quando avevo 22
anni mio padre mi aveva messo davanti a
quello che chiamo il grande bivio
voleva una risposta chiara e univoca in
24 ore
mi spiego meglio
nel 94 ho vinto tantissimo con il laser
la mia prima barca olimpica nel 96 come
tutti sapete c'erano le olimpiadi di
atene
negli stati uniti e io volevo
assolutamente partecipare alle olimpiadi
avevo vinto il mondiale nell'europeo nel
94 nel 95 dovevo semplicemente vincere
le selezioni
dico semplicemente perché era era il
passo un passo normale dopo avere vinto
un mondiale un europeo
voi non vincere le selezioni olimpiche
eppure
avevo cominciato a sbagliare tanto mi
ero iscritto a ingegneria
avevo cominciato a fare ma le due cose
si è l'ingegneria che la vela era un
momento di grande difficoltà non sapevo
cosa fare
rischiavo di non andare alle olimpiadi
da campione del mondo e campione europeo
è stato difficilissimo un anno
pieno di delusioni
a un certo punto mio padre mi ha detto
con fermezza devi prendere una decisione
devi scegliere una di queste due cose
non puoi continuare a fare ma a farne ma
le due e io non capivo cosa cosa volesse
dire mi sembrava assurdo che che lui
potesse accettare che io rinunciassi a
ingegneria o che rinunciasse alla vela
ma dovevo prendere una decisione lui non
ci sentiva voleva semplicemente una
decisione dovevo prenderlo entro 24 ore
il giorno dopo avrei dovuto scegliere se
continuare a fare il bellissimo fare
l'ingegnere
non è stato facile non dormi tutta la
notte però anche lì mi sono ricordato
del mio sogno il mio sogno non era
quello di fare l'ingegnere il mio sogno
era quello di timonare una barca di
coppa america e di sicuro con la laurea
in ingegneria
la rinuncia alla vela non ci sarei
arrivato
allora lo comunica a mio padre un po
spaventato e lui sorrise e miss
l'importante che preso una decisione e
che quella la porti in fondo è che dai
tutto te stesso per ottenere un
obiettivo
ma
da quel momento per me fu un vivo
importante
trovare una motivazione nuova
sapevo di potercela fare anche se ero
molto indietro col punteggio avevo da
recuperare 40 punti su un ragazzo che
era primo nelle selezioni ma ormai avevo
ricentrato rifocalizzato l'obiettivo
vinsi il campionato italiano ultima
prova di selezione con 50 punti distacco
e quindi vinci le selezioni
quando sei in difficoltà e non sai che
strada prendere
fermati un attimo respira attorno al tuo
sogno